When you did your programming with Sarah, it's quite possible that some things
went wrong and you got some nasty error messages. When you learn a new
langauge, be it a human language or a programming language, errors are a fact
of life. Let me show you some common errors so that you can recognize and fix
them. Here's a typical error. Have a quick look and see if you can tell which
part is wrong. That can't be right, the terminal window object was system.out
not system.ouch. Let's see what happens if one makes such an error. You may
want to work along with me here in Blue Jay. Open the errors project and open
error 1. Here is the error. Let's compile and the compiler, the program that
translate Java into lower-level code complains and says it has no idea what the
variable ouch is. The compiler knows system.out, it doesn't know system.ouch.
Such an error is called a compile time error because it's found when you
compile. Some people call it a syntax error because there's something wrong
with the syntax of this statement here. As you can imagine there are lots of
syntax errors you could make. You might forget the semicolon. You might forget
one of these quotation marks or both. You might forget one of these dots. Any
time you do that the compiler will complain and you just fix that particular
error and recompile. It happens to the best of us. Now here we have a different
kind of error, again have a look and see if you can guess. The programmer
misspelled world, let's see what happens in this case. When you compile,
there's no error, the compiler doesn't know English. And it has no idea that
this part has been misspelled. We can run the program and it runs. It just does
the wrong thing. When a program compiles and runs but it produces the wrong
output, then that's called a run time error. Some people call it a logic error
because there's something wrong with the logic of the program not just it's
syntax. Now have a look at this statement, it also has an error. What do you
think will happen when you try to compile and run a program containing this
statement? Do you think it doesn't even compile? Do you think that it compiles
and runs but then it prints the wrong value? Like in this case. Or will it
compile and run and then print an error message? Or will your keyboard melt
into a puddle of plastic? If you have BlueJ open right now, just give it a
quick try.